le technicien jean martin harvey
disparaît sous la coque du navire
la nuit précédente l'immense cargo brise
glaces arctiques est entré en cale sèche
le navire a besoin d'une couche de
peinture on peut mieux inspecter la
coque et évaluer l'ampleur des travaux
maintenant que l'article est hors de
l'eau jean martin harvey c'est un oiseau
rare et la volante s'est quitté
sherbrooke pour les méchins et travaille
chez verreault navigation depuis cinq
ans en région où l'abondance l'abondance
est ici est de la chasse et la pêche
des fois tu finis utiliser un peu plus
d'argent mais pas les pays chauds aucun
de 10 microns gratuit
jean marc hervé c'est l'exception les
travailleurs de l'extérieur sont
difficiles à tirer au méchant surtout
ceux avec des familles ce qu'on a vécu
au cours des dernières années
c'est plusieurs échecs qui sont liées
entre autres à l'accueil et
l'intégration des familles de ces gens à
la halle équilibre entre leur vie
professionnelle et leur vie personnelle
les méchins c'est à près de 700 km de
montréal mais l'habitant des services
minimum une école une bibliothèque
ouverte quelques heures par mois
une antenne du clsc de matane ouverte
deux jours par semaine parce que je
donne souvent comme exemple on peut
adorer son emploi mais si à tous les
soirs lorsqu'on met le pied à la maison
on se retrouve à pleurer à cesson note
yvan hayez certain que ça va être
vraiment ça marchera pas
ensuite il y a les salaires cinquante
mille dollars
c'est le salaire moyen des travailleurs
syndiqués chez vert aux navigations
c'est bon quand on vient de la région et
ses comparables aux autres chantiers
maritimes de l'est canadien
mais si un montréalais veut faire un
coup d'argent dans les mines du nord il
peut gagner plus de 100 mille dollars
plusieurs personnes nous perçoit comme
une région éloignée donc un travailleur
qui va quitter montréal pour venir
s'installer ici à les méchins ou quitter
pour aller s'installer à fermont par
exemple mais pour lui ces deux régions
éloignées c'est un peu la même réalité
mais malheureusement on n'est pas dans
une industrie au moins ceux peu d'offrir
les mêmes conditions de travail que ce
qui vous est offert dans le domaine
minier par exemple quelques incitatif
les employés de l'extérieur de la région
reçoivent chez verreault navigation une
prime de 30 dollars par jour
les cadres disposent d'un logement
gratuit
le temps de leur probation on se
retrouve dans une dans une une guerre
aux effectifs alors le plein emploi ce
n'est pas exactement une bonne nouvelle
quand notre entreprise est installé aux
méchins dans notre corps il est certain
que ça ne contribue pas à notre
expansion
il faut s en être à ce niveau là
toutefois on fait face davantage à un
défi de compétences de notre côté c'est
d'aller chercher des travailleurs
compétents pour se joindre à l'équipe
donc c'est pourtant sur le quantitatif
que sur le qualitatif qu'on a décidé de
miser
parce que par dessus tout cela la
réparation navale c'est une industrie
cyclique pas de contrat pas de travail
des mises à pied alors verreault
navigation fait le pari de la formation
pour garder ses employés
vous voyez ce vieux rafiot abandonné qui
appartenait à la garde côtière
verreault navigation va l'utiliser comme
navire école pas pour naviguer pour
apprendre à le restaurer pendant les
périodes creuses
l'entreprise va garder ses employés pour
les former à de nouveaux métiers ont
contribué à leur progression contribuer
à leur avance marc le point de vue
professionnel tout en maintenant le lien
d'emploi et tout en augmentant doux à
l'internaute efficacité pour les
contrôles à venir jean martin harvey ce
sans billet dans cette entreprise en
expansion
il dit avoir ici un avenir quant à l'
isolement il est réelle dit-il aussi
fait on se fait des amis
oui je te dirais que c'est plus facile
s'intégrer en campagne qu'en ville en
ville ne se parlent pas tes voisins ou
son habitude général mais en campagne
ça se passe strauss kahn même au nom des
panoramas ni même six parties
[Musique]
plein emploi ou pas quand on est une
entreprise installée aux portes de la
gaspésie le recrutement restera toujours
un grand défi